John Green (J): Now I have become pixelated.
Hank Green (H): Yeah, well, you could just
shrink yourself on down.
J: Oh, I see what you did there. You're in...So
Hank is in control of this Google+ Hangout
on air. Um, but, uh, but you know, I'm here,
too. I matter a little bit. Hopefully. Um.
H: Yeah, that can depend....[incomprehensible
talking]
J: But anyway. Hi, yes, welcome to the Google+
Crash Course Hangout.
H: We're doing it.
J: [incomprehensible talking]... which hopefully-
H: Um, I just went to the Crash Course page
to see if this is working or not. It appears
to be.
J: And it is. Okay. Great. Um, so, uh, we
want to start by talking about Crash Course,
and education and what led us to make this
channel. And then we're gonna answer your
questions on Twitter. You can tweet us @thecrashcourse
or, uh, to our individual twitters...um...
@realjohngreen and @hankgreen and we'll be
answering as many questions as we can. But
first we're going to talk about, um, how this
channel came about and why we wanted to make
it. Hank.
H: It was all John's idea. Um. YouTube basically
asked us if we had ideas for original content
programming stuff that we couldn't afford
to do on our own and um... ooh, I need to
enable me. Ha, it's me now. And so we, uh,
we, we came at them with two ideas, both of
them were educational in nature, one was SciShow
and this is also SciShow headquarters here
in Missoula. You can see if this is familiar
to you from the news show, uh, behind me.
Um, and the other was Crash Course and uh,
what we wanted to do was sort of focus on
what, you know, what we're good at, which
is explaining things, and learning things,
and, uh, and sort of something that we thought,
would, would in addition to being entertaining
might actually, uh, help the world be a better
place. Um, so that's how we got started, was
sort of a broad...
J: Yeah, so one of the things, one of the
things that Hank and I always talk about,
when we talk about our ideas, when we talk
about what we, um, stuff we want to make,
is, uh, whether it can do any good. Whether
it can be a useful thing in the lives of the
people who, uh, participate, participate in
it with us. And uh, we felt like both with
Crash Course and with SciShow. SciShow, you
know, committed to sharing, scientific learning,
and Crash Course committed to, um, you know
making educational materials available, free
to everyone that are engaging and fun, but
also genuinely educational. Um, we felt like
both those things could, could do some good.
Um. So we're really proud of Crash Course
and SciShow, and almost, gosh, almost five
months in now. Um, it's been, it's been quite
an adventure, definitely the most fun, interesting
thing I've ever done on the internet, except
for Nerdfighteria.
H: (laughs) Yeah, uh, it's been, it's been
really rewarding to, to watch, uh, as people
sort of actually take the courses and start
from, you know, not much knowledge to a broader,
a broader amount of knowledge. It's also very
rewarding to see people, uh, being like, "I
passed my AP exam because of you!" and, or
"That episode came out right in time for me,
or else I would have been screwed!" Um, so
that's pretty cool.
J: Umm, so, there are lots of people with
questions Hank, so I wanna start asking you
questions, okay?
H: You're gonna ask me questions, okay.
J: I'm gonna ask you some questions, this
is from @russeltospain. Are you planning,
we're answering questions on Twitter by the
way, @thecrashcourse, @realjohngreen, @hankgreen,
are you planning to cover more subjects like
Salman Khan at the Khan Academy? I don't think
he's asking if were planning to cover the
subject of Salman Khan, I think he's asking
if we're planning to, to be like Khan Academy.
H: Umm, dude, that's just generally, uh, very
hard, but, yes. I think that it would be fantastic
if we can get into other topics. Um, Khan
is amazing at, uh, at breadth, and I don't
think that we're ever going to have that breadth,
at least not in the short term. And certainly
not with just the two of us. Um, Khan can
do it all by himself because he's a genius,
umm, and has a different format than we do.
And uh we cannot do it by ourselves, at that
level of depth in all topic areas, which he
pretty much has covered all of them now. He's
pretty much got every topic area there is.
But we...
J: Well, he's certainly getting there. The
Khan Academy, for those of you who don't know
about it, is this incredible resource, that
was really, is really the brainchild of one
person, Salman Khan, and, uh, I mean there
are thousands of videos, educational videos.
But those videos are designed for highly motivated
students. Um, they're, they're long, they,
you know. They're designed for, for people
who, you know, go into the video wanting,
desperately, to learn, and our, our, our video
series, Crash Course is designed, umm, for
more, I guess, casual learners. Umm, you know,
people who, people who see learning as part
of, part of their life, and not necessarily
like just, just school-focused. But also,
you know, hopefully in a way that, that can
be helpful to, to students. Um, Hank, do you
guys have people editing your Vlogbrothers
videos as well as your Crash Course videos,
asks @katiefab (Katie Twyman)
H: (laughs) Oh, I just clicked on the wrong
thing, sorry, I was trying, trying to activate
myself and I paused the video. Um, the answer
to that question is that John and I still
edit our Vlogbrothers videos. Umm, occasionally,
Michael Aranda will help me edit a Vlogbrothers
video. I have him right there.
J: Just pure panic.
H: Um, but, (laughs), we do, we do uh, we
still do all of our Vlogbrothers editing.
And uh...
J: Yeah, I edit all the Vlogbrothers videos.
I mean it's important to note that we also
work a lot on Crash Course and SciShow. Um,
but, as you may have noticed, we aren't great
video editors.
H: I am! I'm a wonderful editor.
J: You're an okay editor, ah, you're, you're
good at jump cuts, I mean, I-I-I don't think
that, you, I don't think, I wouldn't trust
you to make a Thought Bubble, let's put it
that way.
H: Yeah, though, that's, that's, that's more
than just editing, but I, yeah, and I think
that, it's, it's a skill set that-that uh,
we have, we have just sort of been thrown
into, whereas a lot of other people are well-trained.
Um, and so, uh for-for SciShow and Crash Course
we have two full-time editors here, and one
in Indianapolis, so that is a whole different
world for us to have that kind of support.
Um, but yeah, anytime, the only time that
I would ever, like, not edit a Vlogbrothers
video is if there was literally something
I wanted to do that I didn't know how to do,
and that, that's what Michael's for.
J: Yeah, I mean, we still, Hank and I both
feel pretty strongly about keeping Vlogbrothers
its own separate thing, and, and kind of keeping
it the thing that it always has been. Um,
but Crash Course and SciShow allow us to live
our dream of making really educational content,
um, which is what we always wanted to do,
we just never had the ability to do it, because
it takes a big team of people, like, I just
don't know enough about the French Revolution,
um, to make a video about it, you know. And
Hank, no offense, but like, Hank doesn't know
enough about meiosis to make an authoritative
video on it and he certainly doesn't know
enough about illustrating meiosis to, you
know, do all the animations necessary to,
to explain it. Hank you wanna an...you wanna
answer some questions, or do you want me to
keep going?
H: I think that I could, if I had the skills
to be able to animate, I think that I would,
I do have the knowledge necessary to animate
meiosis, but...
J: Whatever, I...you're always saying that
though. I...no one, no one is more convinced
of, of, of his, of his own breadth of talent
than my brother.
H: I-I'm not saying talent, I'm just saying
I-I understand, uh, the basic levels of biology,
otherwise I could not do this.
J: Um, why is the new history show, this is
for me, consistently focused on military and
religion, and why did you choose the particular
narrative that it has? Um, well, it's not
exclusively focused on military and religion,
I also talk a lot about the plague, and in
fact, I think, I think ultimately, arguably,
uh, as I said in, in yesterday's Vlogbrothers
video, um, microbes have a bigger effect on
human history than either military or religion.
Um, but, and there's also, there's also some
focus on, on technology and scientific development,
you know, things like, uh, how innovation,
inventions changed, um, uh, you know, made
the world smaller and made it easier to travel,
for instance across the Indian Ocean, things
like that. Um, but, you know, the focus is,
is on religion, partly because that was the,
or that was one of the focuses certainly,
of lives in the time period that I'm talking
about. So, you know, people, people's decisions,
their values, uh, were shaped a lot of times...uh,
almost always, actually...by, by their religious
beliefs, and as those religious beliefs changed,
a lot of responses to it changed. I'm always
criticized by military historians for not
talking enough about wars, so, I'm glad you
think I talk too much about wars. Um, but
you know, we, I try to be...I try to be as
broad as possible, um, but, you know, our,
I feel like my job is to try to talk about
how decisions that were made over the, by,
by people and also not by people, over the
course of, over the course of world history
led to the world that we have now. And that,
hopefully, will, allows us to, to think, sort
of more broadly, and with greater depth about
the decisions that we're making now that are
going to shape, uh, you know, the world for
the next thousand or five thousand years,
or whenever, um, we end up killing ourselves
off. Hank, what was your favorite...
J: ...episode of Biology Crash Course, so
far?
H: Umm, I don't know, I like the early stuff
a lot, uh, where we're talking about the...like,
I'm a bio-chemist by training and so that,
that stuff was, uh, I get more into that stuff,
despite the fact that most people don't. Um,
so I really enjoyed that. I also really enjoyed
the episode we just did on natural selection,
um, and, uh, because that that's, that's the
area that sort of gets the most attention,
in, in, uh, our world, uh, you know, in terms
of policy and, and like controversy, and I
just like, you know, the opportunity to talk
about that in a way that's not talking about
the controversy and not, like, an argument
between two sides, but just presenting the
information, which I think John did a really
good job of as well, you know, when you're
talking about more hot-button topics in history
like Islam and Christianity, and stuff like
that. So, it's really, really, you know, it's
great to have an opportunity to talk about
these things in an educational context on
the internet, when usually they're talked
about in a polemical context on the internet.
J: Right, I mean, Hank and I are really interested,
really interested, and we have been for a
long time, in de-politicizing traditionally
politicized issues, particularly when they
aren't political, like climate change, for
instance, which is not a political problem,
um, uh, or, uh yeah, or Islamic history, which
shouldn't be a political problem. Like, people
shouldn't be, people shouldn't...but uh, but
it is and you have to, you have to acknowledge
the, the, the complexity of that. Like, I
mean, the weird, the weirdest part about making
that video, which was...that Islam video I
guess was my favorite so far, although I like
this week's, the one that comes, goes up tomorrow,
about Mansa Musa in West Africa a lot. But,
uh, the thing about that Islam video that
made me nervous was talking about, talking
about things that Sunnis and Shi'as still
disagree about. Um, and that, that was actually,
that was where most of the hot-button conversation
was, I mean the rest of the, i-i-it was great,
for the first couple days and we al...we always
experience this Hank, where the first couple
days, the discourse is astonishingly sophisticated
and thoughtful and then slowly it degenerates.
H: There are fewer and fewer comments, and
uh, you start to see, that there will be one,
like usually the crazy comments get pushed
down by the intelligent comments, and then,
eventually there are fewer comments and so
the crazy comments don't get pushed down,
and people feel the need to respond to the
crazy people and then you end up with stupid
conversations.
J: But I do that too, I feel that same urge
to respond to the troll.
H: We have...we have a...
Michael Aranda: I was, I was gonna say that
uh after the video goes up, you're probably
also getting fewer people who are subscribed
to the channel because they're interested
in the content...
H: Right.
M: ...and more people that find the video
because they just Google "Islam."
J: Right.
H: Right, and they are looking for something
to argue about.
J: Let me just tell you, Michael, incidentally,
that, um, if we can get to that point where
you Google "Islam" and the first thing that
comes up is Crash Course...
H: (laughs) That would be, that's winning!
J: We're a long ways, we're a long ways off
from that but...
H: John, I have a question for you. I have
a question for you uh that no one is going
to be polite enough to ask, why do you think
Crash Course history gets so many more views
than Crash Course biology?
J: Because it's about history and not about
biology. (laughs) Um, I mean, it's really,
it's pretty easy to make history populist,
I mean, to make history something that you
would choose to learn about. Um, there's a
relatively low barrier to entry, right, because
we're all, um, we're all human beings living
amid history and we all remember that there
was a French Revolution or something. Um,
when it comes to studying biology, it, it
is, it is, I mean, I don't buy that hard/soft
science distinction, but there is that, there
is that distinction in it. Like, you're gonna
have to learn some terminology, you're gonna
have to pay attention to the way that cells
are built in order to later understand natural
selection. And, uh, there's a relatively high
barrier to entry there. So, I think that's
the issue, although I mean, how astonishing
is it that just, just a few months into this
project, you know, 60 thousand or 70 thousand
people are choosing to watch videos about
mitosis. I think it's awesome.
H: Yeah, yup, I am, I'm pretty consistently
shocked, but what I always say to the people
who are like, "Now what do you do?" and they're
like, "But who pays for that, who watches
that?" And I'm like, well, people who are
learning these things choose to come find
them. Or if they're not even learning them,
they're just curious. And that's the most
exciting thing to me, is that, like, we're
creating content that people come out, like
go out of their way to watch instead of you
know, have to watch in a classroom. Sorry,
I just forgot to click on myself before my
monologue, but now I'm done.
J: Oh, I'm glad people got to see me, see
me listening to you. Um, I have a question
from @philipwhite, and this has also been
asked by a lot of other people, um, it's:
Is Crash Course mostly supported by ads and
by Google, what makes your medium different
from television, uh, and also I've frequently
seen, um, are you guys gonna charge schools
for Crash Course?
H: Umm, we are at the moment supported almost,
well, entirely. We are supported entirely
by a grant from YouTube/Google, umm, and that
is the reason why we can make the content.
Uh, there is a sort of hope that at some point,
uhh, this content could support itself through
advertising or through grants from other organizations.
Uh. There are lots of educational grants in
the world. Umm, and, umm and also through
you know sales of Mongols T-shirts and, err,
and we recently...
J: Err, err, you're right, Hank, that's the
key...
H: Yeah.
J: Mongols. We'll all be rich! (laugh)
H: (laugh) I'm telling you that's the only
path to true success... It's the Mongols T-shirts.
J: (laugh) To answer your other question,
uh, Crash Course is already taught in hundreds
of schools, which is amazing and something
that we are really excited about and really
grateful for. No, we don't charge them, no,
we won't charge them. The whole idea of this
project is to find a new way to make educational
materials possible that doesn't use that old
model of charging academic institutions for
the right to show those, umm to... to share
that... to share that stuff in class, um,
we don't like that model. We think that it's
inefficient; we think that, that schools could
spend their money in different and better
ways. Um, and we want them to be spending
their money in those ways, um and we want
this to be supported through other things,
whether it's advertising or grants or whatever.
Um, so that was the idea of Crash Course,
you know we... we don't like the idea of...
you know having schools fund, err, educational
video because we think there's a market for
educational video. We think people want to
watch it. We don't think people need to be
forced to watch it, um...
H: It's also very interesting to have, uh,
come to the realization that, um, you know
this, these things like what we're doing,
you know, when you do it for free, people
have a harder time taking you seriously, and
they're like, well, one, you don't have a
bunch of money to pay like salespeople to
go into schools and try and sell the content,
and try and like, explain to teachers, like,
like, do a, do a symposium at, like, at you
know a teacher conference, and talk about
how useful this content is, and that's what
all the for-profit institutions are doing,
and so we are in this situation where, we're
creating content that may very well be better,
it's certainly cheaper ('cause it's free),
um, but uh, a lot of places are less interested
in it, because they don't understand, like
how could this be better if it's so much cheaper.
Which is an interesting problem.
J: Right, [laughs] well, but you know, we're
just getting started, so it'll work out, umm,
Hank? Are you looking at Twitter, because
I'm looking at Twitter, I can keep asking
questions, but I thought maybe you wanted
to.
H: I don't know, I don't understand how you
can multitask like that.
J: What do you mean, look at Twitter and also
talk?
H: Yeah!
J: Um, well, I mean, that's, first off, when
you're talking, I'm looking at Twitter, I'm
not listening to whatever boring crap you're
saying, so, so there's that.
H: Ag, uuuh, well there's, uh, there's Katie.
J: Oh, more importantly...no but okay...
H: (laughs) - Uh-
J: Uh-
H: Sorry.
J: You talk, Hank.
H: Uhm, there's Katie who - ooh, shoot - who
asks, "Will Crash Course ever be used for
charitable purposes like teaching people in
third world countries who can't afford schooling?"
J: Well it's already used for that in the
broadest sense. I mean, the great thing about
the mobile internet and the spread of broadband
internet to the developing world, is that
it allows us to sort of take a jump in terms
of infrastructure development, at least hopefully,
so that you don't have to develop telegraph
lines and then telephone lines and then dial-up
and then this and this and this. You can go
straight to 3G or 4G, which means that all
of a sudden not just students outside of schools
in the developing world, but also students
in schools in the developing world have the
opportunity to take advantage of all of the
many educational resources that are freely
available on the Internet, whether it's Khan
Academy or Crash Course or Ted-Ed, which is
doing great stuff, or MinutePhysics, or CGP
Grey -- whatever it is -- and that's really
really exciting to us, and one of the things
that gets us fired up and makes us wanna do
this is the believe that education is central
to development, and that the biggest hurdle
to development on some level is education,
and this isn't...
J: ...the only way, I don't think that it's
a magic bullet but I think that it's one way.
And so I'm...I'm really excited about that,
and it's already happening. We already see
lots of YouTube comments in Crash Course and
SciShow from the developing world, and hopefully
in three to five years we'll see many many
more.
H: I have another question for you, this one
from Samantha. "What is the deal with the
phrase of the week?" Cuz I don't really understand
it either, John.
J: Yeah, it was probably not a good idea in
retrospect.
H: (laughs)
J: And I've never explained it well. So, here's
how it works. Every week, we take a phrase
that someone suggested in comments, and we
put it in the video. We somehow manage to
find a way to insert it into the script of
the video. And, the idea there was that people
would guess at the phrase of the week and
then they would suggest phrases of the week.
But people mostly have found it very confusing,
which has left us with relatively few phrases
of the week suggested, which makes it even
harder to work them into comments, which is
why I had to write an entire episode about
Kim Kardashian.
H: (laughs fully)
J: I was like, "There's no way I can work
Kim Kardashian's name into an episode of Crash
Course. I guess I'm just going to have to
write the episode of Crash Course about Kim
Kardashian."
H: What a disaster! John, a question from
Meeva. "Do you think that Crash Course will
branch out into literature and the arts from
its less literature and arts-based foundations?"
J: Uhm, yeah, I mean we are, I dunno, I'd
love to teach art history down the road, and
I definitely would like to teach some kind
of world literature class. It's challenging
because while everyone is a part of human
history, not everyone has read "Things Fall
Apart." You know, everyone knows there was
a French Revolution, not everyone is deeply
familiar with the plot of Macbeth or desires
to read it again. So I think that's one of
the challenges, but we definitely want to
do it. We just have to figure out the right
way to do it. Whether that's all of us read
the book together and then talk about it,
or whatever it is, whether we focus on shorter
works which most early college classes tend
to do now, for better or worse... I don't
know.
That's something I'd like to do, I'd love
to do arts, art history... I'd love to do
"Comp," like English language and usage and
grammar. I know that that stuff sounds really
boring, but it is actually astonishingly exciting.
I get really geeked out about it, and, like,
when we get to talk about what is and is not
wrong with ending a sentence with a preposition
and what a preposition is and how it functions
in the world and how it opens up the world
of observation to us, I get really really
psyched.
So Hank, what do you want to teach?
H: Uhm, I don't know, science?
J: (laughs) Good job, Hank!
H: Stuff.
J: Stuff?
H: Yeah, more science-y stuff.
J: Do you wanna teach like, uh, physics, or
teach liiiiike, uuuh, geology?
H: Well, both of those are very interesting
to me. I would really like to teach biochemistry,
just because that I just know a lot about
it.
J: Right.
H: I get excited about it pretty easily. I'd
love to have someone teach physics, but I
don't think that I'm the right person.
J: No, I also would love to have someone teach
physics.
H: And I also think, uh, I really... there's
sort of a distinction between sort of hard
physics of, like, of Newtonian and also beyond,
and then there's a discussion of sort of broader,
like, this is how weird quantum mechanics
is. And I like to talk about that stuff even
though at a base mathematical level I am nowhere
near, um, understanding it, but...
J: Could you talk about that stuff without
talking about the math, though? I mean, that's
one of my...
H: Well you could talk about, like, what a
quark physically is, what color charge means...
J: Right.
H: Why they change color, what the weak force
is, what the strong force is, um, you could
talk about that stuff, and you can do it in
a way that's...that's, y'know, lets people
understand it. So you actually get a pretty
marvelously good understanding of the structure
of the universe without having to talk about
math and that...we talk about that stuff on
SciShow. To do a course on quantum physics
would be cool, but probably would better be
done by someone who is not me.
J: Right, that reminds me of when I was writing
Will Grayson, Will Grayson, and I was writing
about Schrödinger's cat, and I had this like,
I had this character, this, this, seventeen-year-old
girl Jane, uhm, going on and on and on about
the mathematics involved in the problem that
led to the Schrödinger's cat thought experiment,
um, all of which, almost all of which was
written by my cousin, Blake, um... It wasn't
even written by me. By my cousin, I mean Sarah's
cousin, Hank's like...
J & H: We don't have a cousin Blake. (both
laugh)
J: Blake who? Blake, he just had a baby, he
didn't have the baby, his wife, had the baby...this
is a disaster of a story, um... but my point
is, that eventually, it became obvious to
me that having this like six-page monologue
from this seventeen-year-old girl about math
I didn't understand was not going to be an
asset to my novel.
(Hank laughs)
H: I just have received word that my wife
has a question.
J: All right.
Katherine: I just think it might be interesting
for people to know what the process is for
every Crash Course video, because I know that
it's different for each of you. So you could
talk about that.
H: I don't know if you heard Katherine but
what she said was, uh, maybe our processes
for creating Crash Course videos are different,
and maybe we could talk about the actual process
behind how it works.
J: Sure.
K: Like Hank's have to be made farther in
advance...
H: ...from beginning to end. Yeah, mine are
made quite a long time in advance. We're about
eight episodes out now. By the time the episode
goes online I'm like "What? I don't remember
that. What is this stuff?" That's not ideal.
J: Ours is filmed well in advance too, um.
I think we're about the same far... the same
amount out. By the way Hank, CGP Grey is watching
us, don't get nervous....but, um, he's asking
questions so I think he's watching us. He
just asked, "How do you feel talking about
subjects on which you might not be experts
yourselves?" To which my answer is, uhh not
so bad. I mean, I'm not a historian at all,
and here I am cranking away like an expert.
I mean, we have educators working with us,
so that's the reason I don't feel that nervous
about it, but it is a little weird.
But to answer Katherine's question, um, yeah
it's very different from traditional video
blogging because...well, I don't know about
you, Hank, but I'm in a studio, and um, Stan
and Danica are there with me, and y'know,
they're there to make sure that, y'know the
lighting is right and all the stuff that I
never understood in video blogging and the
sound sounds good, and that, y'know Danica
makes the beautiful chalkboard illustrations
and all that stuff, um... and then....but
the rest of it really is like video blogging
except that I usually don't make a video blog
from a script because, y'know I'm talking
in my own words about something I care about,
um, and so that is a little bit like video
blogging. I don't know what your experience
is, though.
H: Yeah. But we don't... we write scripts
for Vlogbrothers videos too.
(Katherine saying something in background)
J: Oh, I don't. (Laughs) Do you, a lot?
H: Yeah, I script a fair amount.
J: Wow. I don't.
H: Yeah. I always find it goes significantly
better by script.
J: I do script, uh, the "Thoughts From Places,"
you'll be surprised to hear.
H: Oh, really. (Laughs)
J: Yeah...astonishing.
K: When I think about the Crash Course and
Sci Show, and if you planned the...breadth
of the whole, of the series of videos.
H: Right, so I mean we start out...
(Katherine in background) K: From beginning
to end, what you've planned for. Those topics
are pretty much chosen, right?
J: Right, yeah, so I always start with like
forty topics.
H: We sit down at the beginning of the process,
and we, we y'know, sat down with a biology
textbook, with a biology teacher, with, y'know,
sort of the AP guide to what you're supposed
to know at the end of an AP biology class,
and we were like, "OK, how are we going to
put these into classes?" and we've stuck to
that pretty much. Occasionally there will
be a script that is, y'know, twenty pages
long, and we'll be like "we should probably
do this in two episodes." Uh, but generally,
you can do that.
J: Yeah, when we first started the writer,
Raul Meyer, sent a list of 40 topics he wanted
to cover and we had a little bit of back and
forth about which, you know, which 40 we should
go with and then we, we eventually figured
it out. Although now I wanna make, I wanna
make a full 41st one, because I promised the
last episode would be about the, the t-shirts
and the global economy, which, as you know,
Hank, is something I find completely fascinating,
much to your consternation. Umm, and I really,
really want to make that video so I, we might
have to cut something along the way or I'll
just do a special bonus episode.
Speaking of special bonus episodes we have
a couple surprises, and Hank, do you wanna
crank one of those out now, since we're at
the midway point of our, of our live show?
H: Yeah, let me just get it ready.
J: Okay, Hank is gonna get something ready.
While he does that I will answer another question.
Um, "would you let someone outside the Vlogbrothers
teach in Crash Course?"
Absolutely! Um, you know, the reason that
we haven't so far is strictly, frankly, kind
of a budgetary thing. Um, Hank and I are free!
J: Ahh... we're free and we have a lot of
experience at doing this and we kind of know
how to do it and there aren't that many people
who know how to do it, and those who do generally
aren't free. Umm... a lot of people in comments,
Hank, have suggested that we have Neil Tyson,
umm, Neil deGrasse Tyson teach physics, which
would be great...
H: That would be great!
J: I don't think he's available.
H: Yeah, he's a busy guy.
J: He's got a bunch of stuff going on.
H: This is a very time-consuming project that
we do here. Okay, so I'm going to try to do
this. There's no guarantee that it will work
but we, ah, we have a process by which, by
which we do this, so I'm just going to share
one of my windows, and, uh, and then we will
watch a video.
J: Hopefully.
H: Yup.
J:  Oh...we're recording...oh
God.
Hi, my name is John Green, and this is Crash
Course World Histor-whoops! (laughs)
OW. Hi, my name's OW...my name is John Green,
and I'm the host of Crash Course world history,
and that hurt.
Hi there, my name's John Green, this is champagne
in a plastic cup, and today, we're going to
talk about Egypt, as you might have guessed
from the hieroglyphics behind me. Pardon me,
I'm drunk.
Hi, there, my name is John Green, this is
Crash Course-I'm gonna do that again (laughing)
The fall of Rome, according to-ahh.
Hi, I'm John Green and today's...GOD.
J:  Hank...did you just...go away?
Hank...can you hear...Hank, talk.
(Hank and Katherine mutter inaudibly)
J: Now I'm scared because I'm alone in the
live show.
H: ...and the answer is no.
J: Hank? Hank, I can hear what you're saying,
just so you know. Hank, hi.
J:  Aw, I missed it.
Next week, we will journey to-mmm. missed
it.
J:  Oh, hello, again, Hank!
J:  Is it anti-feminist to never
talk about women except when I'm talking about
how their brutal...
J:  This isn't going well. Can
we exit...
H: I tried. Can you not hear me? (breaks up)
J: ...video. We'll upload it, we'll upload
it so that you can actually watch it instead
of seeing it in a series of apparent screen-caps.
It's an episode of Crash Course outtakes that,
um, that Stan put together. There's also one
of Hank's.
Hank, you're a beautiful black screen right
now.
H: Can you hear me?
J: Can you hear me?
H: I can hear you, but you can't hear me.
J: Yeah, I can hear everything you're saying.
I could hear everything you were saying while
the video was playing too.
H: (laughing) Oh, was I saying...
J: Yeah.
H: Did I say any curse words?
K: Yeah.
J: No, I don't think you said any specific
curse words, but they were implied.
H: (laughs)
J: Um, anyway, is there any way that you can
not be a gigantic black screen, 'cause it
makes me sad.
H: I would also love to not be a gigantic
black screen.
J: I miss when you looked like a Hank! That
was my favorite part of the show...was when
you looked like Hank.
H: (laughs) I also...I love it when uh.....I
have such a good voice though, John.
J: Find a way to turn off the screen-share,
that's the key.
H: Oh, no, I've done that.
J: Oh. You just don't have...is your camera
not on anymore? Do you not have the little
green light that I have?
H: My camera's on.
J: Oh. All right! Rock n' roll, man!
H: (giggles)
J: Um. I guess you should just put me up on
the screen and then you will just be a voice.
H: You're up on the screen.
J: Okaaaay. It's just gonna be me from here
on out, it seems like, so I will, uh...I don't
know, anyway, so we both have, ah, we both
have made, we both made special outtakes videos.
(John's voice played back very loudly from
Hank's end)
J: Hank, that was very loud. Don't do that
again. Um. We both have...we both have special
outtakes videos for you guys, uh, that you
can watch, um. But we'll upload them to the
Crash Course channel or Vlogbrothers or something
so that you can watch them instead of just
doing it this way.
All right, so I guess I will ans...I will
ask some more questions of the disembodied
black screen that used to be my brother.
Hank: [laughs]
John: Um...um...ahhhh... do you do foreign
subtitles at all, Hank?
Hank: Uh...
John: Some one asked it, someone offered to
make Czech subtitles to Crash Course and said
if we, if he made them would we use them?
Or she?
Hank: Let me just switch over to me black
screen so you guys can see me... [laughs]
John: Yeah, please don't.
Hank: Yeah, I mean, we, ah, we are actually
investigating at the moment... [laughs at
John dancing on screen]
John: Sorry, I figured, they can't see you
then I'll do something funny on the screen
to be entertaining, while you are talking.
Do do doo do do do doo [singing circus type
music]
Hank: Um, yeah, yeah, we are looking at, ah,
at an application where, we're looking at
creating an application of sorts that will
allow us to streamline the creation of, of
subtitles to our videos because that's something
that we really want to, not just for Crash
Course and SciShow but for all of the internet,
to...
John: Right.
Hank: ...be, to have access to. Um, we're
just not, we have always felt like there could
be a much better system to do that, and hasn't
been.
J: And the answer to your question, first
off, all the World History episodes are already
subtitled in English. The answer to your question,
"would we use Czech subtitles if you gave
them to us" is yes. Although we don't know
how to use them yet, so we would have to learn
how to use them, but we will. So yes. That
is the answer to that question. Um, someone
says that they're listening to dubstep while
they uh, while they watch us, Hank.
H: Well that's okay, because our, our uh,
manager of the office here listens to dubstep
while he manages us.
J: Wow. Um...that's, that's, that's crazy.
Um, I'm gonna ask you some more questions,
Hank.
H: Okay.
J: You can also ask me questions now that
you are, you are just a black screen.
H: I am.
J: Um, how much of your houses have been turned
into video studios? [Laughs]
H: Only like a third or so.
J: Well, Hank's house is very small, because
it's a green house. Not in the sense that
it's owned by a person named Green, but in
the sense that it is an, uh, eco-friendly
house. Right?
H: Uh...I don't know about that.
J: I don't know, it strikes me as very green.
You have like, bamboo flooring or something.
H: Yeah, it's uh, it's a, it's a new house.
It is...it's fairly small, I guess, by modern
standards... um...
J: Yeah, by modern standards, but whenever
you go into like... That's one of the things
that I've been really into, actually, when
researching Crash Course. And I will let you
finish in a moment, but, you know, since you're
just a black screen right now, I-I own the
video now! Um, but, uh, in researching Crash
Course, I am always astonished by the luxury
that we take for granted that was literally
nonexistent in 99.9995% of the population
until like 80 years ago.
H: Yeah. Well, yeah, when I went to Haiti
and, like, we...I, like, went over to someone's
house, um, and it was their, um, their bedroom,
um, and there was...it was a two-room house,
one of their rooms had a bed in it. You walked
into the door--it had a door--you walked into
the door and there was a bed and there was
a desk and it was maybe, you know, 20 square
feet. And then behind that, there was another
bed and another desk and another sort of room,
and then -- and this was a nice, like, this
was a nice house in Haiti. And then out the
back there was a pit toilet, and, like, that
was, you know, like, a couple of people doing
fairly well.
J: Yeah.
H: And, um, so it's always very strange to
me when people refer to my house as small.
[Laughs]
J: Yeah, no, I mean your house is not small,
but it's small compared to most American houses,
um.
H: Yeah, um, so I...yeah, you know, but we
got, you've got the radiant floor heating
and it's basically a refrigerator in there...
J: Right.
H: ...in terms of letting heat out, um, so
we have to have an air circulation system
or else we'd suffocate, um.
J: Yeah, yeah. That all sounds very fancy.
I just live in a normal American house, because
unlike you...
H: A very normal American house.
J: ...with your crazy Montana wilderness leftism,
I'm an American. A regular, normal American.
[Hank laughs] So, uh, long story short, I
also converted about a third of my house into
a video studio. Um, but my third is bigger.
[Laughs]
H: Right, yes, um... One of...one of my bedrooms
is a video studio, um.
J: Yeah, uh, my whole basement is and then
I do some filming upstairs, as well. Umm...
H: But then, I would show you around our office
and show you, like, 'cause right now I'm in-
I'm in the Crash Course offices, this is not
my house, um.
J: Yeah.
H: I would show you around if you could see
me, but you can't.
J: Um, um, will you, um, will you look at
some questions while- while you're there being
a black screen, so that we can answer good
questions?
H: Yeah, sure.
J: Um, oh, uh, Manu...uh, on Twitter has a
really important question for you, Hank, which
is that have you tried turning it on and off
again?
H: [Laughs] I mean, I could do that, but then
the entire Hangout would end.
J: Oh, uh, there's apparently already a cool
app that Philip DeFranco uses for open source
subtitles.
H: Oh, really?
J: Yeah, it's called, um, captiontube.appsbot.com.
So thank you very much for letting us know
about that, Christine. Um, uh...
J: Okay, Hank. Oh, someone wants Hank to join,
uh, CGP Grey suggested Hank join the video
on a third laptop, which isn't a terrible
idea, um. Okay, um, so Hank, let's, uh...do
you have questions for me, or should I keep
asking you questions? By the way, we're answering
questions on Twitter @TheCrashCourse, and
also @realjohngreen and @hankgreen. There
are a lot of questions about interns, Hank.
I don't know if all these interns live in
Montana or not, but there are a lot of them
so I thought I'd ask.
H: What do you mean by interns? Our interns?
J: Do- Do you have need of them? There seem
to be a lot of people who wish to become your
intern.
H: Oh, um, yeah! I mean, we need people to
help all the time, but I don't know...uh,
we-we also would need an intern to have the
capacity to hire and manage interns.
J: [Laughs] Yeah, sort of the biggest problem
that we have right now is figuring out...is
figuring out that, um. But yes, down the road,
certainly, we do want to have interns, um.
Uh, Crash Course Indianapolis is going to
have an intern over the summer starting, uh,
in a couple weeks, um, and I think that- that
will be great for us. But, uh, I don't know-
I don't know about anything else. Um, um...
do you have any other questions, Hank, or
do you want me to keep going?
H: I'm sorry, the reason why I'm not, um,
answering questions is because I'm trying
to fix the problem that we're having.
J: Okay, well then I'll-I'll answer some questions.
Um, someone asks -- Nigel Prentice asks, "Hey,
how can I score some 2D glasses?" So for those
of you who don't know, my brother Hank invented
the 2D glasses, uh, which are like 3D glasses
except that you go to a 3D movie and you see
that movie in a crisp 2-dimensions. Uh, you
can get them at 2D-glasses.com, is that right
Hank? Whatever, just Google 2D glasses, um,
but yeah. Hank...[Laughs] I think it's...of
all of the things that Hank has invented,
and he has invented far too many things, 2D
glasses are my favorite because they're extremely
funny and, um, also astonishingly useful,
so, most things aren't.
H: [Laughs in background]
J: I'm just gonna keep talking while Hank,
uh, mumbles quietly to his team because apparently
he's not figured out how to mute himself on
video.
H: [Laughs] I did, I figured it out, I just
undid it and then I redid it and then I undid
it again and it was....
J: Yup, well Hank, there's only 15 minutes
left so I'm not sure that there's necessarily
that much purpose to getting your face back
for 10 minutes. I'd rather have a high-quality
conversation between me, my face, and you,
a black screen.
H: Okay, let's do that.
J: Okay, great, so we'll just do what we were
doing until you decided to try to make it
work.
K: Why don't you just [inaudible]
H: Someone asked when I got a corgi because
recently in a video I showed myself with a
couple of dogs, a greyhound and a corgi. Uh,
that was my greyhound. It was not my corgi,
that corgi was named Abby and it sometimes
lives in our office. It is the corgi of our
technical director, Nick Jenkins, who you
will sometimes hear me refer to, as John will
occasionally refer to Stan. I will refer to
Jenkins or Nick. Don't call him "Leroy." He
doesn't like it.
J: [laughs] I do like referring to Stan, but
it has to be said that generally, when I make
references to Stan, it's because of actual
things that Stan did or said moments before
that was recorded. I don't know if that's
true for you and Leroy, but, um...
H: [groans/laughs] Um...yeah. Uh...Yes, Nick
is standing there the whole time while we're
making those videos.
J: Wow.
H: So he'll be telling me to do things and
I will invariably say, "Okay, Mom." [John
laughs] Because he's always like, "Look into
the camera!" And I...
J: A number of people have asked me to, have
asked me to teach a creative writing Crash
Course, which I can't do because I don't know
how to teach creative writing. Um, I have
no idea how to teach such a thing, but there
are people who can do it and I admire them.
But I know absolutely nothing about how to
write a story except by, by doing it. Um,
so I wouldn't know how to teach that. And
right now we're focused on more, um, I would
say traditionally academic subjects that're
maybe undertaught or not taught as well as
they could be at schools. Whereas I think,
um, certainly at colleges...creative writing...there
tend to be really good creative writing professors
because there are a lot of writers who teach
for a living, or for part of their living,
anyway.
H: I've also got a question: uh, are we ever
going to join forces and make an epic history
of biology or the biology of history episode?
J: That would be good. We should do that.
H: I like that idea.
J: I like...I actually think that's kind of
a cool idea. Uh, later on, when...you know,
when we both...maybe in, like, the 30th week
or something, when Crash Course World History
is relatively modern and Biology is relatively
human-focused, it might be really cool to
talk about the relationship between history
and microbes, or to talk about the relationship
between, you know, evolutionary biology and
contemporary history or something. That might
be cool.
H: I'm also really interested in the actual
history of science. Um, like the men and women
who basically created the institution of science
and the people who created biochemistry and
sort of founded of genetics and...a lot of
these people...and...we do a series on SciShow
called "Great Minds"...Is that what it's called?
M: Yep.
H: That's what it's called. And that's been
really interesting to do. We...I don't...I
know this is written, but I don't know if
we've recorded it yet, but we did a great
episode on Fritz Haber. Was that his name,
Mike?
M: We also did the Marie Curie one, right?
H: The Marie Curie one is, like...was featured
in the New York Times and, um, on Jezebel,
which I find equally impressive.
J: [laughs] My two favorite news sources.
H: [laughs] Um, and so people obviously like
those a lot, but Fritz Haber's a super-interesting
dude because he basically saved billions of
people by trying to kill people for the Germans
in World War I and then went on to create
chemical weaponry, and his wife was so despondent
that he was only interested in killing people
that she told him to stop or else. He said,
"No," and she shot herself to death.
J: Wow.
H: And then he went to a party!
J: Wow. Yeah, I mean, they-they-they are,
some...you know, the people who have a big
impact on history tend to be maybe perhaps
a bit eccentric. But I do also think that
it goes both ways, that we also sort of look
to the eccentric stories and put them at the
center of history. You know?
H: Well, I mean, the dude figured out how
to fix nitrogen, which doesn't sound that
impressive but he...it basically made it so
that all of Europe didn't starve at the beginning
of the 19th century.
J: Right. But...but I'm just saying, I'm just
saying there were lots of historical actors,
important historical actors, who weren't crazy.
H: Yes. That's true.
J: I feel like it's an under-appreciated fact
of both the history... of both history and
the history of science like...Cantor, for
instance, hugely important mathematician but,
like, these days, famous mostly for devoting
the second half of his life to trying to prove
that Shakespeare didn't write Shakespeare.
H: Right.
J: Um, and that seems to me, it seems to me
a little unfortunate that we end up conflating
genius and insanity. There does seem to be
a bit of casual relationship between the two.
H: I, ah, I would like to see some data on
that.
J: [laughs] Well, I mean, I, I, I know a lot
of crazy people who aren't geniuses.
H: [undecipherable talking under John] What?
J: I said I, I know a lot of crazy people
who aren't geniuses. Um...
H: It's true.
John: Including myself, um..
H: It's true. I think what, what we really
need to do is, is sort of figure out the per-capita
level of crazy.
J: Right, um...
H: It's prpbably pretty high.
J: Yeah, I don't know, I mean I think it's
probably pretty high. For Hank, besides the
AP Curriculum, how do you determine what to
talk about in the Biology Crash Course videos?
Well first he chooses what's sexy.
Hank: That's true actually!
J: Really?
Hank: Ah, we try and find things where we
can have the title of the video have the word
sex in it.
J: [laughs]
H: Which is pretty easy in biology. (?)
Um, no, it's, ah, it's ...
J: Keep it classy, Green.
H: It's the stuff that I really enjoy, that,
um, eheheh we like to have it all, you know
it's ten minutes long so there has to be kind
of a narrative, um, and so we try and, and
when we're figuring out what to talk about
to create a, ah, a story around it, but generally
we do choose a lot of it based on exact, like,
those, that exact, criteria, which is, you
know we're trying to teach a course here,
and so there's standards that have been decided
upon, and I may not agree with them, but we're
going to agree with them, because otherwise
we're not helping people. So..
J: Right. Yeah, I think it's important, it's
important to note there that, um, Hank and
I, both, when we're making these videos and
really, and also in SciShow and, um, and in
Vlogbrothers too like, we do look for narratives.
We look for ways to tell stories, like even
though I was sick yesterday, and I'm still
quite sick, I apologize by the way if I'm
off my game a little bit, but my, my head
is pounding with tiny chicken poop.
Um, even then, um, I try to make a, a, a story
about Sarah calling me, and telling me that
I had to vote and going to vote, and when,
when I'm making history videos I think about
that a lot, I think about the fact that this
is a show, um...
J: ...and history is a narrative and that's
one of the ways to make it engaging and to,
to, to make the learning process, I think
deeper in a way, is if you can engage with
it as narrative and not just engage with it
as a set of facts that appear to have been,
like, laid at your door step that you now
have to memorize, um, so.. for instance, a
lot of people have asked if there's any way
that we could ever make a Crash Course about
math, or math is just "too boring". Well,
the truth of math is that it's not boring
at all, as you know if you watch Vi Hart videos.
Um, math is really exciting, and it's also
in many ways, very narrative. I mean, Hank
was talking about the history of science but
the history of math is-is, equally exciting,
and, uh, and in the same way that the history
of science is marked by these, y'know, huge
discoveries that then lead to these big consolidations
of knowledge, the same thing happened in the
history of mathematics. And, y'know, talking
about that from a historical perspective turns
it into a narrative and I think it makes it
a lot more fun to learn about, so I do think
there is a way to teach math and to have it
be really interesting.
H: I have a question from moymoymccardo. It
is, "Michael Aranda is awesome!!!"
J: (laughs) I wasn't aware that that was a
question. Um, I've never doubted Michael Aranda's
awesome.
H: (laughs)
J: Um. Okay Hank, people...eeh...Hector Hernandez
says, "Where do you get your information from
in Crash Course and why don't you cite it?"
It's a good question.
H: Do you not cite it?
K: Biology does citations every video.
H: Katherine, who is in charge of citations,
says that Biology does citations on every
video, so this question is clearly for John.
J: Well, biology, yeah, the biology part is
really well cited. Um. We don't-we don't cite
things because, um, I wouldn't know how to
begin citations. So for when we begin, we
talk-we've done a couple of videos-I don't
think any of them have uploaded yet-where
we talk about sort of deep reads of a book,
a famous book of history. So we'll take, y'know,
one of these modern historical classics and
we'll use it as a way into talking about some
historical phenomenon like talking about the
Columbian Exchange, for instance, um, which
was the exchange of microbes and people and
plants and animals between the-Europe and
Asia and Africa, and the Americas. Umm...
and in that we're going to cite a source because
much of the-much of the conversation that
we're having is about a book. But when we're
talking about sort of these broad historical,
um...trends we don't cite sources because
they're not really...that source-y. But I
guess we could do better citations and that's
a good suggestion, and we'll look-we'll look
to it.
H: I do-I will tell you that it is a pain
in the butt.
J: Well, um. That's the other reason we don't
do it.
H: (laughs)
J: I don't like to do things that are hard.
Um. Yeah, do you have other questions? We
have five minutes left in our big show, Hank,
that we're not going to be able to show, and
we have to upload it. Do you think-can we
upload it to, ummm...
H: What we'll do is, uh, is what- we'll have
it uploaded to Crash Course as a video that
is unlisted and we will tweet it from the
Crash Course account.
J: Why can't we list it? Why can't we just
show it to the people?
H: I don't know, 'cause maybe in the future
we will want to- 'cause I don't- 'cause you
have a policy of not putting-
J: Well, we can unlist it- we can unlist it
later.
H: What do you mean? What?
J: We can- we can just make it unlisted later?
H: Oh, I see. Okay. I think-
J: That's gonna work. Yeah let's do it. We're
putting it up!
H: Okay.
J: I-I- Hank, I am the one with the face here.
I make the decisions.
H: (laughs) The face is in charge!
J: The face makes the show!
H: Well, let's...
J: Well, you used to have a face. I remember...now
I'm feeling nostalgic for early in the live
show when you had a face.
H: Sorry, I know.
J: Those were the best parts.
H: When I had a face and I wasn't just a disembodied
voice.
J: Y'know. I always-I always get nostalgic
for the recent past. In this case it's thirty
minutes ago when you had a voice. Um, but
we will, uh. Maybe we'll upload one gag reel
now and one next week. What do you think of
that, Hank?
H: That sounds like a good plan.
J: All right, so we'll upload-we'll upload
mine that you sort of got to see now, and
we'll upload Hank's, which I have to say is
even funnier, and if anything....the thing
that's surprising most about watching your
gag reel, Hank, is watching how often you
had to be bleeped.
H: (laughs) I figured that's what you would
say, just then.
J: Umm...It didn't surprise me how often I
had to be bleeped (laughs)
H: Uhh yes, I uh
J: Yeah.
H: It's a dirty time, there in the studio.
J: Well it's-for me at least it's very high
pressure, because I know we only have...I
know we only have like, y'know, six hours
or whatever to film two episodes, and I get
really mad at myself and I can't say things
right. And, uhm, the way that I deal with
getting really mad at myself is saying words
I shouldn't say.
Michael Aranda: I have a question for both
of you that's kind of related to that. Before
you guys did Crash Course and SciShow, you
both mostly just filmed by yourself, in a
bedroom or whatever, without other people
around, so what was the transition like, having
to go into a studio, where all of a sudden
you've got someone working the camera, and
someone doing script supervision, and y'know,
for Hank there's like, snake handlers in the
room or whatever.
J: Right. (laughs)
H: There were snake handlers.
J: Right. I mean, one of the keys to my success
is no snakes,
H: And what? No snake handlers?
J: I don't do well with snakes and I don't
do well with people who do well with snakes.
H: Oh. Um, yeah, it was definitely a transition
the first time I went into the studio, and
I was like, "Okay, there's people in here
with me." I was not very natural, I was not
very comfortable. Umm. I have gotten over
that, it's still definitely more pressure
than filming at home, and I definitely feel
drained afterward, and I'm like, "Oooh, I
need to go to sleep now", and-oh, good I'm
glad that you have that. We have a wrap-up
question, an excellent wrap-up question from
CGP Grey.
J: Well can I first-can I first answer that
question that Michael just asked?
H: I thought you did, already.
J: No.
H: Okay, well-
J: I-I only had a joke answer. The real answer
is that I didn't feel awkward at all but it's
because it's Stan and Danica. Like, the other
day a reporter for the Chicago Tribune was
watching me record and I was super bad...umm,
and not in the good way, but in the genuinely
bad way. Umm, I was really awkward, and I
was talking too fast and I couldn't get my
lines out and it was really interesting, because
I just, I had a level of comfort with Stan
and Danica immediately that I just don't have
with most people and it was a good lesson,
which is that, um, I can't do it in front
of just anyone. It has to be the right um,
the right people, so it's because I'm friends
with them and I like them, and they're nerdfighters,
and it doesn't feel awkward. If it feels awkward,
if I feel like I'm being watched, I get very
bad.
H: Yeah. Yeah we had like six people in the
studio the other day because we had a bug
handler, and he came in with some giant bugs.
J: Bug handler!
H: Really cool...
J: Wow, I do not like bug handlers.
H: Um, some giant rhinoceros beetles that
are like the size of your fist...
J: Shut up.
H: (laughs) and they had- and we brought in
a-he had a pupa, he had a rhinoceros beetle
in the pupa stage...
J: Aw God...
H: ...in a hard casing but it's like writhing
around. it's sooo cool.
J: Ugh god. You how know I know that Henry
is my son, Hank?
H: What?
J: Before we get to the wrap-up question can
I tell you how I know Henry is my son?
H: No.
J: We saw a beetle the other day, and we were
walking in the woods and we saw a beetle,
and Henry said, "Daddy, beeeetle!" and I was
like "Oh God!" and I pulled him away, of course,
because y'know beetles are very harmful potentially.
H: (laughs)
J: And about five minutes later we were just
walking along the edge of the White River
and Henry looks up at me and says "Daddy,
beetles, scawwy!" (laughs)
H: (laughs) I was, ah, I wasn't particularly
comfortable with the rhinoceros beetles but
I was very excited by them.
J: Yeah, I mean this beetle was the size of
maybe a roach, but even so I was terrified.
H: Yeah.
J: Aaughh...pfwoarrgh...alright so moving
on, what's the wrap-up question from our friend
CGP Grey?
H: Our friend CGP Grey says, "If you're looking
for a wrap-up question, where do you see Crash
Course in a year or two?"
J: That's a great question, I'll let you handle
it.
H: No. Just a black screen talking.
J: (laughs)
H: Umm...I ahh, I think that there are multiple
paths for Crash Course, and they all excite
me and some of them are smaller scale and
some of them are much larger...um. What I'd
really like is for there to be broader infrastructure
behind the videos where it's not just a video,
but it has a place where it lives, there's
a sort of a better question-and-answer system
than YouTube comments, there are potentially,
like, worksheets, or... other resources whether
or not they're physical or not. Umm, ways
to, ways to reemphasize the information you've
got into your head during this Crash Course
episode because watching a show is one thing,
but watching it and taking a worksheet or
taking a short quiz to reinforce it, and then
a couple weeks down the line, doing that again,
you really end up with a lasting knowledge
of the topic, and that seems like the sort
of thing, like an innovation on top of an
innovation...
H: ...that could really be powerful. Umm so
that's something that I'd really like to do,
but as far as it being significantly different
than it is now, just more of it, hopefully.
J: Yeah. Yeah, I'd like there to be more,
I'd like there to be more teachers and more
courses and more, more stuff, that's the first
thing that I would like, and I would also
like, what Hank wants. Um, and I'd really
like to expand the idea to include background
on historical events, so for instance, when
you see the Greek debt crisis, or when, y'know,
Greece is having a debt crisis, which these
days is usually, Crash Course could provide
a place where you could go and get background
both on debt crises and traditional sovereign
defaults over the course of history and how
that generally affects national economies,
and whether austerity historically has led
to faster recoveries than defaults, and questions
like that, but you could also get historical
background on Greece's economy, or if you're
looking at the Syrian riots. Not riots, I
should say revolution. But you can go and
you can get background on the history of Syria
over the last hundred or two hundred years
that will allow you to have a better-formed
opinion about news stories that are going
on today. So I see that as within the idea
of Crash Course and what Crash Course is really
about and what we can do well. So I'd like
to expand it into that as well.
H: That's wonderful. Umm. This is an exciting
thing that we're doing together, John.
J: Aww, thanks. I hope so, I mean, they decide
if it's exciting, not us. But we are having
fun doing it and it's a real privilege to
be able to do it and we feel really, really
lucky so, uh, thank you guys, all for watching,
and thank you for being awesome, and Hank,
thank you for being a black screen so that
I could be the star of the show, that was
very generous of you.
H: (laughs) Yeah, thanks to all 4,152 of you,
sorry to leave you in the cold, but we will
still be on TheCrashCourse on Twitter, and
you will see our first outtakes reel being
uploaded to Crash Course, youtube.com/crashcourse
momentarily.
J: All right. Don't forget to be awesome!
H: DFTBA.